jeden tag macht ich bin freier freitag
von loring hoffen auf den weg in hitlers
bunker labor durch die zerstörten
straßen berlins knapp acht meter tief
als adjutant bereitet er die
militärische lagebesprechung vor viele
viele stunden verbringt der gemeinsam
mit hitler in einem raum die letzte
besprechung des tages beginnt oft erst
nach mitternacht und dauert bis in den
frühen morgen
alle die dabei sind wissen die
militärische situation ist auswickeln
den 22 april bezeichnet losen als seinen
persönlichen schicksals tag am 22 april
fand die letzte wirklich noch große
führer lagerhalle bestäubung weiterstadt
aufzuführen
bei dieser gelegenheit kam es
zu einer darstellen der lage durch jodel
und durch krebs die katastrophal war
sowohl im westen als auch im osten
frank j
krebs kam also auch sichtlich gezeichnet
also aus dieser der beschreibung heraus
und sagte unsere hat mir dann alles
erzählt das was da passiert war und das
war also erstens dass hitler zum ersten
mal zusammen gebrochen ist dabei er hat
also den krieg zum ersten mal also als
verloren haben gesehen bereit
ihr führer denke ich daran aufzugeben
er bleibt in berlin keitel und juden
haben den auftrag entlastungsangriffen
von süden von westen und von norden
einzuleiten hörer setzt auch generell
denke ich zwölfter mir wirklich noch
dazu auf die natur und auf die kuppel
steinerne noch ans laufen
wer will dass ich mich ab sofort in
seiner unmittelbaren nähe aufhalten
werden also hier
sie wissen natürlich was das bedeutet
meister meldet sich zur stelle
gutes jährlichen sind wir sind praktisch
auf uns alleingestellt sie und ich
wir können oder solchen umständen die
nachrichtenlage überhaupt erfassen für
berlin sind sie zuständig für die
internationalen ereignisse gibt es ja
heute ist die englische
nachrichtenagentur haben sie die bessere
und damals habe ich dann dazu
entschlossen die meldung die über den
reuter funk also im britischen vom
britischen radio ausgestrahlt wurden und
dann habe ich geschaut was melden die
engländer
welche städte sind also wieder erobert
worden wo befinden gefechte schlachten
stadt und weiter und daraus habe ich
dann den lagerbericht also für hitler
zusammengebastelt natürlich hat man sich
dabei gedanken macht gibt es eine
möglichkeit dass hierzu noch zu
herauszukommen zu entrinnen bleibt also
nur noch eine letzte frage
und die wäre google oder kapsel keine
sehr einladenden alternativen hat sich
entschlossen bunker zu sterben er
keinesfalls die absicht als partisan in
den bayerischen wäldern herumzuirren
oder gar leben den russen in die hände
zu fallen
und als germanische beste in einem
panoptikum auf dem roten platz zur schau
gestellt zu werden
christian die tore des klassischen
französischen cognac ihre nicht
auszugehen
und dann hat man sich ja durch
erschießen oder soll man dem nicht den
mund schießen mit pistolen
denn die kapsel ich habe keine gekriegt
aber die die großkopferten haben dadurch
solche kapseln da die leute haben alle
gar nichts mehr zu tun
sie beschäftigten sich dann also mit dem
der frage was passiert wenn es nur der
russe also in die bunker eindringt für
die zurückgebliebenen im bunker ist klar
die situation ist völlig aussichtslos
werden sich viele bereits hier unten mit
dem tod abgefunden haben nimmt loring
hofen all seinen mut zusammen und stellt
seinem vorgesetzten
die entscheidende frage wirklich
verlassen
ich bin kein freund länger general
aber soll ich hier noch tun
vor zehn minuten ist die letzte mit den
telefonverbindung abgerissen wir haben
keinerlei kontakt mit der außenwelt
eine militärische funktion ist damit
beendet
geben sie mich fragen und das war
natürlich also ein ziemlich wagnis
reiches unterfangen denn genauso gut
dann sagen können sie sind an dieser tür
und ich stellen sie verstand gelegt hat
während erschossen mit viel glück
erreicht vater von loring hoffen dass
amerikanische besatzung gebiet
kurz vor einem wiedersehen mit frauen
kind gerät er doch noch für zwei jahre
in kriegsgefangenschaft 1956 in den
führungsstab der neuen bundeswehr
berufen gelangt er vier jahre später als
einziger deutscher in den strategie
statt der nato als stellvertretender
generalinspekteur der bundeswehr geht er
1973 in den ruhestand